some people are trying to use Chain of
Thought as an interpretability method
and I think we need to move Beyond this
and engage with the internal mechanisms
I believe that ambitious
interpretability is possible
or at least that if it's not possible
that's striving for it will get us to
interesting places
these models have legible algorithms I
want to try to reverse engineer them a
third difference is engaging with the
actual mechanisms and computation and
algorithms learned
there's also work on things like
analyzing features of a model probing
individual neurons and I take this as
very relevant to macintub but I want to
make sure we aren't just looking at
what's inside the model but also trying
to understand how it computes features
from earlier features what applying
causal interventions to understand the
actual mechanisms making sure we're not
just doing correlational things like
prepping